look at this gorgeous new iPhone 6
bigger display that new camera I am so
happy I camped out here for four days to
get this thing oh these people and their
new iPhones sure the new phones are
great but what about those of us who are
not eligible for an upgrade or just
simply don't need a new phone well with
iOS 8 available as a free download on
September 17th this iPhone and even this
iPhone can feel like those brand new
ones no you won't get that new roomie
screen but you will get most of what's
new and what's been fixed in the phone's
operating system ok sure
this place looks exactly like iOS 7 but
you'll find most of the new stuff in the
apps you use everyday an iMessage you
can now easily share your location and
send video or audio messages that expire
it's easier to respond to messages right
from the notification alert and it's
easier to contact your besties right
from here the Photos app is better too
with new editing tools like the ability
to finally tweak exposure and brightness
there's also this new icon on the screen
the health app it measures your activity
using your phone sensors and can also
bring in information right from your
jawbone or Fitbit app Apple has big
plans for this especially with the new
Apple watch but right now I find it
complicated to use the best new feature
is getting the iPhone to talk to your
Mac when the next version of OS 10
called Yosemite arrives you'll be able
to take phone calls right on your
computer you can also instantly pick up
an email you start it on your phone when
you come into close proximity I always
say it also brings some major fixes to
things that have long been broken you
can finally write an email and then
quickly go back to your inbox
it also can scan your email for contact
information so you can easily add it to
your address book and I'm considering
throwing a little party for the new
keyboard no really and very excited
about this borrowing a page from Android
it suggests words you might want to type
I've had far too much fun building
sentences solely out of the words my
iphone now suggests
you are so cute when you get a new phone
case
send this predictive typing speeds
things up but the new third-party
keyboards are even faster SwiftKey my
favorite Android keyboard is now on iOS
and it's really fun to use all the fixes
aside there are still some very weak
spots in this operating system Siri wake
up seriously what have you been doing
with yourself I know you can recognize
music now but you don't make my life any
easier I still have to ask you for
information unlike Google now or
Microsoft's Cortana which feeds me
information when it knows I need it the
organization of the operating system
also still feels stale to see my most
important information or notifications I
still have to pull down here that said
iOS 8 is a big and smart upgrade the
apps you use the most are better
third-party apps are more integrated and
your phone is primed to now talk to your
laptop your home and your body it's
almost like getting a new phone
except for that $200 plus a whole
two-year commitment thing and the curved
edges the bigger screen is a brand new
camera and the NFC for payment